MEGAN O'KEEFE: Hi.
I'm Megan O'Keefe.
AMEER ABBAS: And
I'm Ameer Abbas,
and we're both part of the
Google Cloud Platform team.
Our job is to make Cloud
easier, and we do this
by creating demos, posting them
on GitHub, doing presentations.
As a matter of fact, we're here
at KubeCon 2019 in San Diego.
We had a great presentation
about virtual machines
as part of your
Kubernetes ecosystem.
Now I know what
you're all thinking,
what are we talking about
virtual machines at a KubeCon?
The harsh reality is
that most customers
we talk to all have
virtual machines running
in their environment.
These could be databases,
legacy staple applications.
Even if they're migrating
their applications
over to Kubernetes,
they need a way
to talk to these applications.
And for that, we're using
Istio, which is a service mesh
technology that Megan is
going to talk a little bit
more about.
MEGAN O'KEEFE: Yeah, absolutely.
So the way to incorporate
a virtual machine
into an Istio service
mesh running on Kubernetes
is really easy.
All you have to do is
install the Istio sidecar
proxy and the Istio node
agent on the virtual machine,
and then configure it
to call home to Istio
running on the cluster.
Once you do that, it's really
easy to see all of the metrics
and logs for both pod and
VM workloads in one place.
And it's really easy
to apply policies
like role-based access
control and encryption
on both environments.
If you're interested
in learning more,
check out
bit.ly/life-outside-the-cluster.
Thanks.
AMEER ABBAS: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]